J.R.R tolkien's the Lord of the Rings
trilogy is one of the most important
works of fantasy ever written and is a
touchstone upon which many of today's
Fantasy worlds and creatures are based
the world of Middle Earth gained even
more popularity when Peter Jackson
adapted the Lord of the Rings into a
film series that managed to capture its
unique appeal and the settings and
characters that Tolkien created have
continued finding new fans to this day
much of the appeal of The Lord of the
Rings comes from the impressive cast of
characters that Tolkien conjured up for
his Timeless fantasy Saga at the core of
these is Frodo Baggins and Samwise gamji
his steadfast and loyal friend Sam
Begins the story as a risk-averse
gardener if I take one more step
it'll be the farthest away from home
I've ever been but by the end of the
tale he's been transformed into a
legendary hero on the same level as any
Among The Fellowship of the Ring it's
perhaps for this reason that J.R.R
Tolkien considered Samwise gamji to be
the true hero of the Lord of the Rings
remarking in a letter to potential
publisher Milton Waldman in 1951. I
think the simple rustic love of Sam and
his Rosie is absolutely essential to the
study of his the chief Hero's character
tolkien's assertion that Sam is the
chief hero is probably no surprise to
Lord of the Rings fans though Frodo
Baggins takes on the task of bearing the
one ring to Mount Doom he begins to
falter over the course of his long
journey eventually deciding to take the
ring for himself when it finally comes
time to destroy it meanwhile Sam's time
with the ring sees him single-mindedly
devoted to saving Frodo and he never
even considers keeping the cursed object
for himself Sam overcomes his humble
beginnings to defeat a giant spider he
also slays a tower Full Of Orcs to
rescue Frodo and is so formidable an
opponent that the Orcs believe him to be
in legendary Elven Warrior finally when
Frodo can no longer walk it's Sam who
carries him up Mount Doom so that he can
complete his task still there's even
more to Sam than this Samwise the brave
I want to hear more about Sam
[Music]
Oda wouldn't have got far without Sam
J.R.R Tolkien had some real-life heroes
in mind when he created the character of
Sam as reflected in a 1956 letter to
editor H cotton mention which read my
Samwise is indeed as you note largely a
reflection of the English Soldier
notably Tolkien served in the British
military during World War One and as
such witnessed great acts of heroism
first hand the author admired these
soldiers so deeply that he wrote that
they were quote so far superior to him
when a man with the same name as the
heroic Hobbit wrote to Tolkien in 1956
Tolkien said that it was an honor to
have that name writing back the Sam
gamgee of my story is a most heroic
character even though his Origins are
rustic with these words in mind it's
clear that Tolkien admired Sam just as
much as readers and viewers have come to
for Generation sense
foreign
[Music]